pour léa étudiante les recherches n'ont
pas été difficiles
dans quelques jours elle emménagera dans
ce petit appartement au centre-ville
proches des commerces et des transports
et qui plus est dans un bâtiment
historique
tout juste restauré bah moi j'ai
commencé à chercher fin juin début
juillet j'en ai visité deux donc avec
celui ci tournait maximum dans les cinq
sens beaucoup de bailleurs
professionnels craignaient un effet
comique 19 il n'a pas vraiment eu lieu
malgré les incertitudes sur cette
rentrée universitaire et des cours en
présentiel
les étudiants n'ont pas hésité à
s'engager on a tous 6% au niveau de la
demande en logements étudiants par
rapport à l'année dernière
là on va dire que c'est un petit peu
repoussé au niveau des délais puisque on
a plus de personnes qui sont venues
courant juillet à cause du confinement
mais on a une demande qui est toujours
aussi forte et on a pu satisfaire
quasiment toutes les personnes qui sont
venues en contact chez nous pas de
tension donc sur le logement étudiant
une constatation qui vaut également pour
les 2500 lits gérés à besançon par le
crous
les opérations continuent encore puisque
nous avons régulièrement des
désistements ont parlé de la cascade
parcours c'est donc ce sont des
logements que nour proposons
immédiatement en vitrine sur notre
application et les étudiants peuvent
encore faire des demandes de logement et
obtenir satisfaction
on va dire dans les dernières minutes
avant la rentrée le crous poursuit la
rénovation de son parc locatif
si certaines chambres sont toujours très
petit elle dispose de plus de commodité
donc toutes les chambres sont équipées
d'une cabine très fonctionnel c'est à
dire un ensemble un bloc disposant
dallara beau d'un wc et d'une douce des
chambres qui sont loués prioritairement
aux étudiants boursiers
mais puisque la demande n'excède pas
l'offre quelques non boursiers pourront
en bénéficier